[Musique]
on aujourd'hui porte de versailles
un mondial tech qui a le salon de l'auto
qui va commencer le mondial de l'auto
qui va commencer demain aujourd'hui
c'est réservé uniquement à la presse
donc ça on en reparlera d'ici quelques
jours on va retourner le voir je vous
montre un truc en attendant qui est
assez cool c'est une porsche
regardez ça que dans un espèce de deux
containers géant bon sens voire parler
du pari motor show d'ici quelques jours
pour l'instant on va se concentrer sur
l'univers de la têt cas le csn veille
aujourd'hui il ya mondiale tech il ya
pas mal de trucs cool donc poursuivre
toutes ses actus je vous invite bien
évidemment à vous abonner à rester
connectés
[Musique]
nous sommes donc aujourd'hui mondiale
tech alors est ce qui est extrêmement
intéressant ici c'est qu'on voit qu'on
parle vraiment de smart city on parle
également de voiture
là
vous avez pas mal
l'illustration est ce qui est vraiment
intéressant à comprendre ici c'est que
mon des tec se déroule dans l'enceinte
même du pari motorshow du mondial de
l'automobile
vous avez une grande confiance ligne en
arrière ça se passe directement dans le
cadre du salon du mondial de l'auto à
paris donc on voit qu'il ya pas mal de
choses qui s'agrège vous avez d'un côté
toute la partie automobile moto
d'ailleurs qui se rejoignent cette année
au mondial de l'automobile on a un côté
un peu smartcity problématique de
l'urbanisation autour de véhicules
problématique autour des voitures
autonomes des transports publics
vous avez des illustrations comme ici
derrière avec le transport public
complètement autonome on va retrouver
dans les villes d'ici quelques années
donc des véhicules sans aucun chauffeur
est ce qu'on voit et ce qui est vraiment
intéressant ici c'est donc vraiment se
le lien est ce qui se fait en plus avec
le crs 1 de veille qui est là cette
année
donc vous avez le cm5 veuilles qui a
lieu aujourd'hui même donc vous avez le
pari motor show vous avez mondiales
telles que vous avez le service en
veille tout ça au même endroit c'est le
montre bien qu'il ya vraiment un sens
commun c'est-à-dire trouver les
solutions smart cities voiture
connectivité tout ça pour avoir une
vraie solution complète pour demain et
c'est vraiment ça qui est vraiment
intéressant ici là on voit qu'on a une
problématique pour recharger votre
voiture pour faire 200 km en à peine
cinq minutes donc ce que je vous propose
c'est d'aller faire un petit tour
maintenant du côté du service en veille
pour aller voir
ce qui s'y trame qu'est ce qui va se
passer au mois de janvier à las vegas
parce qu'on va y aller on va lui faire
un tour ensemble moi ça ça va à terme
aux besoins tant qu fais toi
alors stephen on a déjà parlé stéphane
stéphane qui a les mondes connectés
timide pour enfants la non qui vont
arriver bientôt saint-marcel et latin
c'est vrai ce mardi exactement mais
ravis il explique c'est quoi un final
assez récemment
alors c'est une compétition que
organiser toutes les start up
qui participe au css et
le tanneur mes écrits
dans la catégorie
lifesize
un espoir pour les entreprises qui
s'installent au coeur c'est tout le
monde génèrent généralement localisées
sur les enfants mais a priori cela vient
cool on leur convenait de 100 marchés
l'amour oui normalement dans un mois on
peut
distribué non
trouvé sur steam est pointée vers
il y aura dans la description donc là on
est sur le sol us and mail qui a
commencé il ya beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de monde de tous les côtés il
ya plein de start up était hyper
intéressante
il ya plein de choses qu'on la voit donc
ce que je vous propose c'est je vais
tourner la caméra de l'autre côté et qui
ont baissé de regarder un brusque à
droite à gauche alors là l'idée c'est
vraiment de regarder de façon générale
prendre un petit peu l'ambiance et on
détaillera tout ça quand on sera au mois
de janvier à las vegas là on pourra
prendre davantage le temps de regarder
quelles sont les solutions quelles sont
les différentes start up
qu'est ce qu'il ya d'intéressant enfin
toute la journée ici sont intéressantes
va parler tout à fait à trop de choses à
dire on va essayer déjà peu de prendre
la température
donc là vous avez énormément de
différentes start up ou s'il ya des
choses plus pur
le côté déplacements relo vous avez
aussi de l'enceinte connecter avec pas
d'âme qui est juste là une enceinte très
sympa alors ça on en reparlera aussi
ultérieurement
vous avez plein de choses vont bien
évidemment il ya toujours à boire et à
manger ça ça ne change absolument pas il
ya plein de solutions sur l'intelligence
artificielle ça on va le détail est
aussi très très prochainement va
beaucoup parler de l'intelligence
artificielle hop là pardon pardon
messieurs dames il ya vraiment de belles
choses à dire et puis surtout ce qui est
intéressant c'est que vous avez aussi
une présence des régions là typiquement
c'est la région sud provence alpes côte
d'azur
il ya beaucoup de choses là on est sur
une imprimante 3d qui est en train de
vous imprimer un petit à petit chez us
voilà donc ici c'est vraiment un vivier
de start-up toutes sortes d'entreprises
même sur de la chaussure ça aussi on en
parlera quand on sera au cs mois de
janvier il ya énormément de choses bien
évidemment la vr est toujours à
l'honneur
donc ça aussi
on fera un petit point là dessus c'est
génial sur les événements comme ça comme
les csn bay c'est déjà trop un petit peu
la température voir un peu les tendances
qu'est-ce qui va se profiler
on voit que le smart cities quelque
chose qui va vraiment se développer on
reste toujours bien évidemment sur les
objets connectés
lorna le stand darcos qui est juste là
les écrans les enceintes leçon il ya
plein plein plein plein de choses de
tous les côtés pardon mesdames messieurs
il ya beaucoup de monde il ya aussi un
live ici qui est fait par 01net qui en
direct en ce moment même donc comment
taille 3 les embêter plein d'europe je
me faufile une solution hyper hyper cool
y aussi des guides de voyage leurs hôtes
et quick
juste là on en parlera aussi quand on
sera au cs l'année prochaine avec une
christophe il ya plein de choses à dire
il ya aussi mes collègues de air pur qui
sont juste là qui a un regard un masque
qui vous permet de garder des points de
vie lorsque vous vous déplacez ça c'est
aussi quelque chose de 10 père du père
intéressant qu'on en a déjà parlé on
reparlera aussi d'air pur un peu plus
tard voilà donc là il ya plein de choses
à voir c'est vraiment hyper hyper
passionnant l'audio est aussi à
l'honneur directement ici sont des
solutions dont on reparlera
ultérieurement plein plein de choses
vraiment vraiment passionnant donc voilà
on essaye un petit peu de prendre de
voir un peu les tendances ayew se s est
dit bien évidemment vrai avec maxime de
business france la french tech alors mon
maximum étude de le voir maintenant
maxime donc la clcv sun veille le crs
dans quelques mois et pour les gars on
est prêt pour vegas alors là il ya pas
mal de start up qui expose qui seront
présents si sur le pavillon français
oui bah en réalité tout en a même une
dizaine aujourd'hui way qui partent avec
business france mais tu en as beaucoup
plus qu'ils partent avec des régions
ouais
ces régions par david despin adresse
avec la french tech dont l'une sera aux
couleurs de la french tech ce joli col
rouge que tu verras où partout beaucoup
beaucoup sur le rica par yellow rica
parc c'est la zone réservée aux jeunes
startups innovantes et donc aujourd'hui
c'est un peu le la preview quelles
seront les grandes tendances qui sont
les meilleures startups tu verras las
vegas et ont été annoncées notamment des
nominés pour les vinovèl chinoise et
cette année il ya 56 français nominés
pour les innovations et les très grands
gagnants les best-of seront annoncés
lors du cs rennwald de new york
d'accord qui aura lieu quand courant
janvier courant janvier mais voilà juste
avant saison juste avant le cs et après
on recroise un corps tout le monde avec
haas school tu ne pourras pas rater les
français veulent voir c'est quoi la
grande tendance pour toi là qui va se
dessiner sur le cms de l'année prochaine
dans ma vie ba aujourd'hui tu
tu peux pas passer à côté de la mobilité
les mousesports la smart cities a
précisons peut-être que le noise pour la
première fois la nouvelle paris se
déroule pendant le mondial de l'auto le
mondial de l'auto à créer le mondial
tech
j'ai juste à côté de nous donc si le cs
et le mondial de l'auto se met ensemble
on sait qu'il ya quelque chose à faire
je repense à notamment le fioul de ford
l'année dernière qui au csa avait fait
une grosse conférence sur la smart city
à aucun moment il n'avait parlé
d'automobiles d'accord n'a présenté
aucun modèle dont tu vas y à il ya un
truc à faire dans la mobilité
nous on retrouve toujours de l'instant
l'intelligence artificielle évidemment
entreprise française qui développe là
dessus
énormément honnêtement la france a un
gros vivier de l'intelligence
artificielle
c'est plutôt en haut
l'état français est de beaucoup en la
personne de
villani il ya un rapport sur qu'est-ce
que nous avons beaucoup de choses pour
les personnes âgées dans la santé en
général
et tu retrouves toujours un peu de
fitness et quelques produits quelques
produits du quotidien qui va retrouver à
la maison
qui est partie toujours assez rigolote
mais utile très utile du team bon enfant
le tout ça en janvier il est trop beau
ce qui se retrouve à vegas il retrouve
tout le monde avait
c'est une très bonne idée bon vous
restez connectés parce qu'on va partir à
las vegas tous ensemble on vous emmène
cette fois ci a donc là on avec
christophe christophe qui allaient
eurotech oui alors leurs hôtes et quid
je pense pas que ça parle à les joueurs
au grand public qu'est ce que tu peux
présenter leurs techniques bien ce que
tu fais tout ça on va écouter
oui leur technique c'est un événement
qui réunit tous les acteurs de la tech
en général on est très présent sur le
sol us de las vegas mais comme
aujourd'hui pour le thunder était venu
sur mondial dès qu'on a fait une
conférence
on est présent pour permettre aux
entreprises de sa culture et à la
transformation numérique parce qu'on se
rend compte qu il ya plein de gens qui
savent pas ce que c'est il le suivisme
et software vous avez alors les
indicatifs pour les entreprises ont fait
exactement frénésie alors deux choses on
les aide à comprendre
ouais et surtout on les aide derrière à
se transformer s'ils ont besoin d'avoir
un accompagnement d'accord ce qu'en tant
que dirigeants d'entreprises
entrepreneurs c'est pas toujours facile
de faire les comptes
ils ont besoin de conseils
[ __ ] dresse au score aux start up aux
grosses structures également ce taux aux
structures surtout incorporer des deux
pays les pme aussi puisqu'elle se
transcende
allez on les amène vers les smartphones
pour que l'iss parker explique quelles
sont leurs innovations est ce que ça va
leur a pas d'accord sur un event comme
las vegas typiquement csg organise
et rendez vous oui d'accord quant à
combien de rendez-vous commence à
s'organiser un petit peu tout ça alors
on a deux axes le premier axe est celui
sur lequel je travaille depuis la visite
guidée c'est à dire qu'on va visiter le
salon quand
musée et on doit s'arrêter sur des
stands comprend qu'ils paraissent les
plus pertinents qui sont vraiment
distractif et l'autre billet c'est avec
le réseau internet
c'est une plateforme européenne qui
permet d'organiser en parallèle des
salons des rendez vous
start up et les investisseurs
aux acheteurs la question qu'a fait le
déplacement qui sont participants de ce
rendez donc ça tu le fait que les
startups françaises ou internationales
européennes c'est quand mon intérêt mais
leurs hôtes equities suis-je bête six
bêtes d'accord d'encadrants dégoût du
cms là c'est la nouvelle ce matin par
une présentation exactement aux
thématiques
oui et tu vois d'autres rendez vous au
théâtre st denis alors nous on s'était
rencontré sur les fins ait atteint donc
en général effectivement se déplace il
ya plusieurs salons qui proposeront des
mobiles ovi
mais nos spots c'est vraiment le cs
parce que c'est là qu'un gros lancements
produits il ya vraiment des innovations
qui en général de total on pense à
l'asie mais on y pense
ok bientôt l europe commence à
travailler que les ailes des jeannois et
c'est merci monsieur tron c'est ça pour
un coût de ma fille qui te raconte
revoir à tout ça en détail avec grand
plaisir de tout ce qui est super c'est
que là vous avez vraiment toutes les
grandes tendances vous le dis aussi bien
de lo'jo les écrans l'intelligence
artificielle
la réalité augmentée la réalité
virtuelle le côté smartcity les
problématiques de déplacement la voiture
connectée les objets connectés
c'est vraiment tout le futur qui réuni
ici tout futur technologique qui réussit
qui réunit ici en un seul et même lieu
le csn veille à paris le cs on y sera
d'ici quelques temps on va aller à vegas
vous allez voir avec as avec un truc de
fou je vous ferais bien évidemment comme
d'hab
une vidéo par jour on va les prendre et
tendances on va les voir les nouveautés
on va les voir ce qui se passe on va les
voir ce qui se trame
on va essayer de comprendre un petit peu
de quoi va être fait notre avenir de
futur technologique
on ira voir des les diamants grosses
entreprises les gros mastodontes les
samsung deir ezzor est où tu sais très
grosse boîte on voit un petit peu les
produits je dirais plus grand public
qu'on peut avoir directement on ira
également voit des petites start-up des
technologies ip reniche et qu'on ne
connaît pas encore aujourd'hui et qui
vont arriver dans nos objets demain
après demain voir dans dix ans ça c'est
cool ça permet vraiment de voir ce qui
va arriver très prochainement
de quoi sera fait notre avenir
technologique par quoi est ce qu'on va
passer et c'est vraiment super
passionnant donc tout ça on va en
reparler très vite donc à faire une
seule chose pour rester connectés et
vous parler de deux technologies c'est
bien évidemment à vous abonner et à
rester connectés
[Musique]